well even though covid restrictions have  been loosening a lot of events are still  up in the air right now like the  electric daisy carnival  currently still on track to take place  at the speedway the weekend of may 21st  that's coming up soon  organizers just announced they have  submitted safety protocol plans to  officials and will know by april 8th  if they're allowed to have the festival  if it's not approved they will move edc  to sometime in october they did that  last year too of course that didn't end  up happening  organizers say if you do have a ticket  to edc but don't feel comfortable  going you can transfer your ticket to  next year instead or  just get a refund the